>> With Android, you can easily customize
your home screen just like you can on the
computer. Android allows you to adapt your
handset in many ways. Tailoring the look of
your home page is simple by changing the image
for your wall paper. You can do this with
a nifty feature across Apps called “Long
Press.” Every time you select and hold an
item on the touch screen, you find an additional
set of actions. Using “Long Press” on
the home screen, I can select an existing
image from the wall paper gallery, go to the
web to grab an image, or choose one from my
picture album. You can also customize the
applications on your home screen. You can
select Gmail, or other useful Google Apps
or Bonsai Blast, even bookmarks for websites
or sites you want easily accessible. What's
great is that you can do this with contacts
and Gmail labels you frequently use as well.
Android fits your diverse lifestyle. You can
create a work page, or play page, an entertainment
page, or a communication page, making it simple
to navigate your needs as you move throughout
the day.